can I ask you a question you have a
friend of your daughter staying with you
correct yes what does she call you she
hasn't said my name oh she just showed
up last night so she hasn't said oh
hello Mr O'Brien or do the kids friends
call you Mr O'Brien yes because that was
something that happened started in grade
school is that apparently the word went
out you call parents Mr O'Brien or Mrs
O'Brien and they do that and I used to
think that's a little formal I don't
know that I need that but the second a
kid says Hey Conan
I want to tear into their torso with
like my sharpened Nails pull their heart
out and eat it in front of them maybe an
overreaction or proportionate thank you
yeah proportionate yeah the minute I
heard and my son once a number of years
ago when he was a little realized
that all he had to do was say my son is
quite large now and and older my son is
in his late 50s but my my son said okay
Conan and he and I said like okay okay
and he was like all right I'll try
better Conan I'm like well it's you know
I'm daddy and you call me dad or daddy
and he knew that it's it really does
push a button oh it really he really big
timed you there yeah and what about you
what do you want kids to call you Mr
Melanie yes yeah sometimes I say call me
Dr O'Brien no you're not a doctor I'm
not do you have uh do you have honorary
degrees I don't know who knows those
things he does he does yeah from
Dartmouth Dartmouth that's pretty cool
huh why'd you laugh then
why'd you laugh if it's so cool it's
great you were expecting a different
school didn't you it's great that
Dartmouth
what's Cornell book that
get the dishes
get the dishes for Dom DeLuise
blooper reel on you ripping into
different schools
I gave a speech there they I was not a
prerequisite I didn't ask for it they
gave it to me I got a Bachelor's we got
a p you got a doctorate you gotta
doctorate what wow was it arts or
something yeah Arts of course Arts yeah
what do you mean what do you what are
you scientists in my own way I'm a
scientist you know in the in the 1700s
you would have just taken over your
Dad's job and you would have been
assigned yeah your dad would have
dropped dead when you were 15. yeah and
I was still being alive that's insane
yeah it is insane you're like 60. my dad
my dad's 60 and you walk around with a
dad my dad at this point you guys should
be brothers
you should just be brothers my dad my
dad is 94. he fought in the Boer war
look it up kids
yeah he fought oh come on and uh yeah
he's uh he's still going strong but
you're right in the olden times oh yeah
where my father to first of all no one
lived past 50. uh he would have dropped
in the field uh and I would have taken
over his medical practice and I would
have been a phrenologist I would have
measured the felt the bumps on people's
heads and decided if they were
sociopaths or not yeah so that's the
kind of thing and I would have been very
respected yeah it would have been a
better life for me then you would have
been working you would have been
training to do that from a very early
age yeah you had no child the people
always go oh poor Michael Jackson he had
no childhood but you know who else
didn't is anyone born before 1910 yes
yeah and they didn't marry children with
a giraffe as a witness yeah
is that the first hard take you've heard
on MJ yeah you never yeah it's a pretty
sacred cow in comedy to not go after it
we now know wow we now know Sona a lot
of people have negative takes on it we
now know why John was not asked to give
the eulogy at Michael Jackson's funeral
I had a nice version I read your nice
version new version I read your nice
version exactly what the that's exactly
what the host said I read the nice
version and it leads with the whole
giraffe no childhood thing I had a
version without that and I was perfectly
willing to call in an audible and switch
it on the Fly and the organizers knew
that but did I get LED in the Staples
Center no
you know I
Sona was a new hire when Michael Jackson
shuffled off his mortal coil
backwards and um
come on he moonwalked off that mortal
was new and I called her from the car
and I said this is terrible about
Michael Jackson she said yeah and I said
okay well here's was that a test that
was the final no and then I said uh you
know just a range of like a private
viewing all that stuff and I said I want
a private viewing and um and I heard her
writing it down like private viewing and
I said so just
find out who we talked to like sometime
alone with Michael and I said I I don't
I don't want to run into Tito yes and I
really don't want to run into the dad
and you sit and I heard you going I just
started just started yeah so I came to
work and the first thing I did was March
into her office and she was starting to
make calls and I saw in her pad she had
listed all of the things that I had said
yeah you don't know Joe Jackson
wanted to adopt blanket that was a
separate call two days later okay but I
told her no that was just a joke but
then I called you again two days later
and said uh I want to um
can you get in touch with my lawyer
we're like okay and I said this is her
name and it should be in there and
you're like okay and she's gonna need to
figure out we're also going to need to
talk about adoption law and again and I
said yeah and she said what's this on
she said I I I'm going to want to adopt
uh blanket and she just hung up on me so
that's when I hired just just started
working for him like I was so new
and he didn't care I would I would I
would believe him too yeah it's just
he's a stone's throw from Michael's
Inner Circle I I what
who worked with my yes yes I'm I mean
yes thank you it's Conan O'Brien I don't
know why I was calling him yeah okay no
no I could get I that would have been
fine that would have been you wouldn't
have known I wouldn't have known at
least at the ready that he didn't you
know introduce him uh during the uh
black or white tours you know I wouldn't
know in the I wouldn't know because I
didn't do that yes because I was uh a
known person when you were young right
and so for all you know I partied with
you know Al Jolson like I you know any
anyone from the 1920s you linked me to
all those people yeah yeah it's very
plausible sure